The eight long, pointed legs of a massive
spider, fangs dripping with deadly venom,
skitter across the ground. It is one
of the apex predators here… Until
it’s crushed by the scaly foot of SCP-682,
the Backrooms’ newest, angriest resident.
When we last left our least favorite anomalous
reptile, SCP-682 was eight levels deep into the
terrifying extra-dimensional labyrinth known
as The Backrooms. With SCP-343 knows how many
levels left to traverse, the hard-to-destroy
reptile was beginning to feel a bubbling sense
of contempt for everything in this godforsaken
reality. That is to say, SCP-682 felt the way it
usually felt, but for once, there were no feeble
Foundation personnel to unleash its rage on.
And while its long absence
back in the world outside of
The Backrooms has been seen as a stressful
inconvenience for most of The Foundation,
the fact that the keter-class creature had done
no further harm since it evaded containment had
led many researchers to believe that, however
unlikely it was: SCP-682 no longer existed.
“It’s out of our hair!” said one Dr. Wazowski.
Though the Foundation would continue to
launch around-the-clock reconnaissance
missions the world over, the Mobile Task Force
that seemingly did the deed of destroying the
hard-to-destroy reptile was currently
being treated to a company pizza party
paid for by The Foundation’s “Sorry A
Lizard Ate Your Loved One” Fund which
received a small donation from the O-5 Council
every time that SCP-682 breached containment.
But there was no chance of relief for
SCP-682 itself, as wandering through
The Backrooms without a map or strong sense of
purpose was certainly no pizza party. Level 8,
the level that SCP-682 currently found itself
on, was a cave system crawling with all manner
of hostile entities. Well, hostile for weak and
pathetic human beings at least. To say the same
was true for SCP-682 would be a gross distortion
of the definition of the word hostile, especially
because SCP-682 had faced many of these miserable
monstrosities before on the previous levels.
The Clumps, Hounds, Death Rats, and Smilers were
back in droves, and these now all too familiar
entities seemingly couldn’t help themselves
from aggressively pouncing on SCP-682 the
second that the reptile entered their line of
sight. Not that getting the drop on the anomaly
would buy them any advantage, as SCP-682
effortlessly bodied them one after another.
Playing the hits already,
Backrooms? SCP-682 thought to itself. At
least give me something new to chew on.
Through the jumble of stalactites and stalagmites,
SCP-682 could see a child faceling standing on
the other side of an unusual pit of tar. The
last time that SCP-682 encountered a few of
these unfittingly named faceless little girls
during its time on Level 2, it had ignored the
entities out of a sense that there would be more
interesting monsters to destroy going forward.
SCP-682 now realized, almost shamefully, that it
had largely been proven wrong. Perhaps the child
facelings were in fact more than meets the eye,
or knew something that the other entities didn’t.
Regardless, there were never enough pathetic
cretins in The Backrooms for SCP-682 to vent its
nigh-limitless frustration on. The small faceling
would simply be the next to bite the dust. Or so,
SCP-682 thought. As the hard-to-destroy
reptile charged towards the entity,
its claws touched down on the puddle
of tar, and almost immediately:
a countless number of human hands emerged from
the liquid beneath and pulled SCP-682 under.
The anomaly was able to easily adapt the
level of strength necessary to escape from
the grasp of the tar pit entities and
resurface. When it emerged, however,
the child faceling was nowhere to be found.
SCP-682 had to give the creepy little menace some
credit as it was apparently smarter than the other
entities which had crossed the lizard’s path.
SCP-682 put as much distance between itself
and that annoying tar pit as it could,
and it was vigilant for any other similar
hazards. Not especially amused by the concept
of being swallowed up again, SCP-682 adapted a
pair of large draconic wings which it used to
carry itself aloft through the caves of Level
8. From above, the anomaly could see a number
of foot-long centipede-like entities as well as
entities that resembled eyeless chickens, and
for once, neither of these horrendous mistakes of
creation seemed interested in assaulting SCP-682.
It was surprising, but SCP-682 actually felt a
little bit relieved. Not because it felt remotely
threatened by anything that crawled, trotted, or
slunk through The Backrooms, but because it didn’t
have to waste any of its valuable time putting
down another weakling that should know better.
This relief was short-lived as all of
a sudden, a large shape dropped down
on SCP-682 from the ceiling. This monstrous
humanoid boasted four powerful limbs and was
currently using all of them in an attempt
to pummel SCP-682 back down to the ground.
SCP-682 could see several similar entities
emerging from the nearby cavern walls, having
apparently blended in through color-changing
camouflage and lying completely still in wait
for prey or in the case of SCP-682, the
anomalous lizard that would prey on them.
These entities are called Camo Crawlers
by the Major Explorer Group, and because
they have the same level of intelligence as
regular humans and cooperate to hunt in packs,
they are regarded as one of the more difficult
entities to deal with. Not for SCP-682,
of course, and the hateful beast could not be more
disappointed in this latest ill-conceived ambush.
SCP-682 came to a landing on part of the cavern
floor which was decidedly not covered with tar
and allowed its wings to retract back into its
body. Without a moment to spare, it quickly made
short work of the Camo Crawlers. The lot of them
may have been as smart as humans, but SCP-682
had killed a lot of humans in its time, and an
extra pair of arms wasn’t exactly a game-changer.
Now surrounded by a record number of expired
Backrooms entities, SCP-682 realized it was
growing sick of Level 8. It seemed that
there was no winning with this place,
as the levels that SCP-682 had visited
previously either contained hordes of
worthless expendable fodder like this one or
were so empty that the SCP would find itself
longing for any kind of interaction. It was
time to search for an exit to this level with
the hope that the next inconceivably vast maze of
nothingness had a more refreshing flavor to it.
Knowing the Backrooms, the exit to Level 8 would
probably come in the form of an off-color portion
of cave wall or some glitched geometry straight
out of those video games that younger humans
seem to love to play. Fortunately, SCP-682
didn’t have to think too hard about how to
progress to the next level, as after
wandering around for long enough,
it merely fell straight through a random
section of the floor into darkness.
Seconds later, SCP-682 appeared in
the lamppost-lit streets of Level 9:
also known as the infinite suburb.
It looked close to midnight,
and much like in Micheal Jackson’s hit song
Thriller, evil things were no doubt lurking
in the dark. But none eviler than
the hard-to-destroy reptile itself.
If Level 9 was anything like the suburbs that
SCP-682 remembered from its native reality,
this place should be filled with humans packed
together like sardines in a can. And while the
lucky Foundation Mobile Task Force that was
present at the site SCP-682 had no-clipped into
The Backrooms at were likely enjoying some sardine
pizza for a job well done, SCP-682 was fixing to
make the next humans it encountered into its
own kind of unconventional topping for a feast.
It was feeling oddly rejuvenated and
almost happy again, and what it didn’t
know was that the darkness of Level 9
had the same anomalous - or I suppose,
vaguely supernatural - properties of Level
6. And as the research suggests, many kinds
of emotional inversion fields that unnerve and
disturb ordinary humans make SCP-682 feel the
opposite way. It was strange, but somehow SCP-682
felt almost like it belonged here in Suburbia.
Just a little old me in a big big world.
SCP-682 mused to itself, before
trotting down the pavement through
the neighborhood. Its mouth was
starting to water as it carefully
deliberated over which of these sleepy
community homes it would enter first.
The idea that behind every door there were
unsuspecting humans fresh for the slaughter
made this place seem like paradise for the
reptile. This rare good mood even remained as
a new group of quote-unquote “hostile entities”
made their way down the street towards SCP-682.
Alright then, let’s meet the welcoming committee.
These entities were known as The Neighborhood
Watch, and the most relatively interesting thing
about their appearance was that their anatomy
seemed to be centered around singularly massive
eyeballs. Without hesitation, one of the
cyclopean entities, a floating eyeball known
as a “Watcher” fired a piercing ray of light at
SCP-682, which instantly disintegrated portions
of the reptile’s body on contact. Unlike the
corrosive acid used by the death moths and the
bursters from Level 5, the damage inflicted
on SCP-682 was at the atomic level.
What this effectively meant is that the
regeneration time to recover from these
injuries was going to be slightly longer than
usual. The other advantage that The Watchers
had was strength in numbers, as there were
three of them, as well as a pair of “Striders”:
ambulatory eyeballs on 8-foot legs which
brought up the rear of The Neighborhood Watch.
“Two can play at that game!” said SCP-682.
It instantly copied The Watcher’s disintegration
rays, firing a pair of atomic lasers from both
eyes that would make a superhuman blush. These
lasers of heat and light hit their marks with
perfect accuracy and dismantled the particles of
the entire approaching The Neighborhood Watch.
As per usual, The Backrooms then
proceeded to roll out the usual
clown car of stooges. SCP-682 could see
Death Moths, a couple Skin Stealers,
and some particularly wretched Wretches
hiding among the suburban homes. The reptile
made a sport of using its newly adapted
laser-vision to pick them off one by one.
Zap!! I see you! Zap!
Before long, there were no more Backrooms entities
in sight, and SCP-682 decided that it was time
to break into one of the houses on the street
and go to town. Or technically, go to suburbia.
Honey, I’m home! SCP-682 thought to itself
as smashed through the front
door of one of the buildings.
Inside was no trace of habitation: no food,
no photographs, and absolutely no humans.
Oh well. Thought 682, still mellowed out from the
effects of the darkness. There’s always next door.
It exited through the hole in the wall it made
and strode across the lawn to the
next little house on the square.
Knock knock!
SCP-682 burst in once more, and found this
house to be in much the same state as the
last. Undaunted and feeling persistent, SCP-682
made its way down the street like a terrifying
door-to-door salesman: busting through
the front door of every house in its path.
Telegram!
Special delivery!
I’m here to talk to you about car insurance!
There was nothing. No humans anywhere. Level 9
seemed to be one big empty ghost town. SCP-682
started to consider the implications of the number
of entities it had encountered earlier. While they
were little more than distractions for SCP-682,
the chances were very slim that any humans that
had made it this far could have survived
such a plethora of dime store goofballs.
SCP-682 let out an
uncharacteristically wistful sigh.
The Backrooms got me all messed
up. I can’t believe I’m actually
missing those disgusting humans. I’ve
grown accustomed to their faces.
SCP-682 reflected on this for a moment
and then had another realization.
No, this is perfect. I’m free! I may
never see those worthless creatures again!
They’ll never inflict their pathetic
existence on what is mine. I am free!
SCP-682 howled in private triumphant victory
as it rambled through the streets of this dead
world unknown to humans and especially unknown to
The Foundation. This was nothing like the endless
office space of Level 4, because the darkness
negated any possible depression that SCP-682
could develop as a result of being deprived
of other entities to interact with. Even then,
it was clear that there would be more than enough
entities for SCP-682 to destroy if it got bored.
While there was no telling how often entities
in The Backrooms spawn or where they really come
from, there never seemed to be a shortage in
the levels where they did exist. SCP-682 began
to think that Level 9 was in fact the paradise it
appeared to be at first glance. Against all odds,
SCP-682 had achieved genuine bliss, and it
seemed that nothing could take that away.
As SCP-682 stood there staring up into
the starless black void of Level 9’s sky,
it was caught off guard by the sudden
presence of what appeared to be a blue
hyacinth macaw landing on its back. The bird
had given no indication that it was nearby,
and because of that, it had somehow taken
SCP-682 completely by surprise. What’s more,
the reptile was feeling an unusual
sensation within its mind. It knew,
almost instinctively, that this avian entity’s
name was Jerry and also that it was one of the
only beings SCP-682 had ever encountered
that it didn’t outright want to destroy.
It wasn’t that SCP-682 liked Jerry or even
really cared if he lived or died, but there
was something about this unusual macaw
that didn’t trigger the usual disgust
response that every other form of
life brought out in SCP-682. This
wasn’t admiration or friendship, but
more like… optimistic indifference.
“Your existence is acceptable, Jerry,”
said SCP-682 to its newfound winged
companion. “Let’s go find some weaklings to kill.”
“Squawk! Weaklings!” Jerry replied.
And so SCP-682 was off again, this time with Jerry
in tow. It was the two of them against the world,
and together, they could take on anything. SCP-682
and Jerry out on adventures! Running around and
accomplishing great things in The Backrooms!
One hundred years of SCP-682 and Jerry!
Eventually, the asphalt and suburban houses gave
way to an unpaved dirt path leading through a
field of wheat. Within moments, the darkness was
replaced with a dense fog, and the black of the
night sky changed into the gray of a cloudy
afternoon. SCP-682 breathed in the moist air,
and realized that once again, it had moved between
levels of The Backrooms without knowing it.
This was Level 10, the infinite
wheat field. At this point,
the word infinite was starting to feel cheap.
“Some warning would have
been nice,” SCP-682 grumbled,
no longer feeling as serene without
the benefits of Level 9’s darkness.
At least Jerry was still here. There
was a silver lining to everything.
No!
SCP-682 stomped its feet on the ground in
building frustration. It needed to find
something to tear to pieces immediately, or it
might reconsider even its tolerance of Jerry.
The macaw was now its last resort in case
there were no other entities on this Level.
Fortunately for Jerry, SCP-682 became alerted
by the echoing sounds of trumpets coming from
further into the wheat field and decided to
investigate. Through the mists of Level 10,
SCP-682 could see the silhouettes of several
large stone towers. SCP-682 didn’t recognize the
exact time period of the architecture, the way a
human might assume they were from the middle ages,
but it could definitely tell that these were
old. It hadn’t destroyed something like this
in ages, and it seemed as though
it would soon be given a reason to.
Perched high on the towers were a small
patrol of goblinoid creatures wielding
bows and arrows. These entities spotted
SCP-682 around the same time it spotted
them and began to nock arrows from their
quivers and open fire relentlessly on the
reptile. These ancient projectiles stung,
but compared to the disintegration rays
from the Watchers, SCP-682 saw
this as a bit of a downgrade.
The only real harm that it did to
SCP-682 was spiritual, as the rain
of arrows seemed to startle Jerry and cause
the macaw to take flight away from SCP-682.
“Jerry!! Get back here, you coward!!”
SCP-682 shouted to the birdlike entity as it
disappeared from sight. It shook its head.
However brief it was, it seemed that the
682 and Jerry team-up had come to an end.
Stupid bird. He better hope I don’t see him again.
The Archers continued to
pepper SCP-682 with arrows,
but the reptile wasn’t about to take medieval
warfare lying down. With extreme speed,
SCP-682 charged at the nearest tower and rammed
it head-on. The impact shook the structure,
causing the archers to stumble and drop some
of their arrows. Despite the damage, the tower
hadn’t fully crumbled, so SCP-682 underwent
a brand new adaptation to settle the score.
Armored plates converged at the end of
SCP-682’s tail, forming a large bludgeoning
club similar to that of an ankylosaurus. With
the power and speed of 682’s body behind it,
this bony mass was more accurately
described as a wrecking ball.
And it came in like a wrecking ball, too,
as the reptile swung its whole body with
enough force to smash the base of the
tower into pieces. As the stone fell,
so did the archers, and many were buried
beneath the rubble while others scattered,
retreating to farther towers
while taking pot shots at SCP-682.
The reptile didn’t chase them. It had bigger
plans. It waited until the archers had made
their way into the next few towers before
grabbing a piece of rubble in its mouth and
chucking it directly up into the air. The
chunk of stone flew upwards and then began
to descend rapidly towards the wheat field
below. Demonstrating an eye for precision
on par with the siege engineers of medieval
times, SCP-682 swung its club tail at the
perfect moment to hit the falling stone
and change its course. It was a home run!
SCP-682 scored a direct hit on the top of the
next tower, and repeated its stone-chucking
strategy until the Archers began to get
the message. This was a war the likes of
which these Freddy-Freaker-looking demons had
never experienced. The hard-to-destroy reptile
roared a blustering battle cry and began
to berate the entities for their weakness.
“You miscreants deserve this for scaring Jerry
away!” SCP-682 said without really thinking.
What had gotten into it? Some strange anomalous
effect? It pondered this as it continued to
perform its rather convincing impression of
a catapult. The archers had completely taken
cover at this point, afraid to retaliate
for fear of getting a rock to the face.
Not too long after, the same trumpet noise could
be heard again, and the area around the towers
became a lot less active. It did take SCP-682 a
moment or two to realize that the entities had
all disappeared with the sound of that instrument.
Cowards would be cowards, after all. The reptile
was aching for more of a fight, but at the very
least, Level 10 was offering something new.
Though not all of it was new. A Smiler peeked
out at SCP-682 from between stocks of wheat,
and this time the reptile simply chose
to ignore the uncanny grinning bastard
and move on. No sense giving
it the satisfaction, right?
SCP-682 followed the dirt path for about a
day, during which time it also encountered a
pack of hounds, a skin-stealer, and who could
say how many death rats that scampered amidst
the field. After all this, it came to what
appeared to be some kind of settlement. The
buildings here looked much more modern than the
towers, and unlike the empty suburbs of Level 9,
the reptile could see that there
were actual humans living here.
From all appearances, this appeared to be a
small town square with an open-air trading
post much like a farmer’s market. In addition
to wheat, the humans living in this settlement
had all sorts of goods on display and could
be seen actively bartering with each other.
SCP-682 licked its lips. None of those helpless
fools knew that it was coming. Malt Town,
as it was known to wanderers in The
Backrooms, was about to receive a rude
awakening at the hands of a keter-class
SCP. While the archers that had been
encountered earlier posed a definite threat
to those straying too close to their towers,
the entities seemed to conveniently
ignore this humble little town.
Of course, mercy was not in SCP-682’s playbook.
Except for when it came to Jerry, apparently,
but the macaw was gone now, and it was
time for carnage. This was going to be fun.
go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?” and “SCP-682 Slaughters
Through the Backrooms” for more Backrooms carnage!